hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up today a warning for Earth
campaigners say a third of the Amazon
rainforest is on the verge of total
Destruction
the environment secretary tells The
cop27 Summit in Egypt that Britain must
maintain its Targets on global emissions
despite the growing economic crisis
Nicholas sturgeon says her government
will drop a long-standing claim about
how much energy wind energy Scotland
produces as opposition parties say her
figures are misleading
[Music]
thank you hello and welcome to the Daily
climate show where we track the changes
to our world and interrogate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis now we start this afternoon with
breaking news environmental campaigners
say large parts of the Amazon are moving
closer to Oblivion on biodiversity day
at the cop Summit on climate change a
report from the WWF claims that part of
the rainforest could be lost forever
within years our sounds correspondent
Thomas Moore is here so Thomas they said
it's about to reach a Tipping Point what
exactly does that mean so a Tipping
Point is a change to a system within the
Earth that can't be reversed so once it
starts it can't be stopped and it does
lead to very significant changes now
what WWF is saying is that 34 of the
Amazon is reaching a threshold for this
Tipping Point where it would lead to
irreversible Decline and eventual death
by 2030 and you can see on the map here
in pink they've got areas where the the
the rainforest has reached one of these
shipping points in the darker the red
the more tipping points they've reached
now what are the Tipping points they're
looking at well there's there's things
like how dry is it how long is the dry
season how much Forest has been lost and
a rainforest the clues in the name needs
to be wet to sustain itself and if it
does begin to dry out it becomes a
savannah there's more likelihood of of
fires and that kind of stuff and that
really is bad news yeah it's
unbelievable to think about it what does
it mean for climate change on the whole
though well there is no scenario that we
can get to 1.5 degrees without a healthy
Amazon because once that Forest starts
to die all that carbon that's been
stored within the wood is just released
into the atmosphere it is a carbon bomb
and that is what really terrifies many
scientists that this is uncontrollable
and that's why WWF is campaigning for
governments to act now because there is
still time to save the Amazon but time
is running out okay Thomas thank you so
much
well um the wfwf says that as we were
saying the wnf has said that it's
reaching a Tipping Point let's go to
cop27 now and it's three weeks since she
was appointed in the environment
secretary Terri's coffee is attending
her first major climate change event
she's at top 27 in Egypt speaking in
sessions about biodiversity and the
impact of climate change on our seas
there are just two days of the summit
left before world leaders try to agree a
new plan for reducing global warming
let's speak to our climate reporter
Victoria Seabrook she's in trouble shake
for cop27 so Victoria big event for the
new environment secretary what has she
been saying
do we have Victoria yes indeed so I sat
down with her earlier and we talked
about a number of things I asked her
about migration obviously we've heard an
awful lot about that recently because
and the thing is climate change is a
huge driver of migration that's only
going to grow as extreme weather events
get worse and also slow onset things
things like drought and she said that
yes uh overseas development Aid and
climate Finance is an important lever
that we can pull to help slow migration
abroad and that's significant because we
are hearing serious concerns that the
government May further cut overseas
development Aid budget and we also spoke
about insulation and Energy Efficiency
it's the Autumn statement tomorrow there
is a conservative 2019 Manifesto
commitment to spend nine billion on
Energy Efficiency which would of course
help people lower their their energy use
and therefore their bills I said will
that be protected she didn't want to be
drawn on that here's what she had to say
well I'm very conscious the challenges
that people are facing and things like
food inflation as well but we need to
continue to make sure that we preserve
nature we restore nature we improve
nature because they're all
interdependent they're intertwined and
this is about taking action today but
it's also about taking action for the
future and for generations to come and
people will have seen some of the
moments we've had since Paris we've seen
increasing extreme weather events have
been happening not only at home in the
UK but around the world and that's why
the urgency is so very real I'm
disappointed that we weren't able to get
the targets out in the time that we were
supposed to I'm very conscious that the
primary target about halting
biodiversity loss by 2030 is is in a
legislation already so but I will be
we're working at PACE to get those out
and making sure we have also the
delivery plans the environmental
Improvement and plans ready by the end
of January as well so it's important
that we get those right because they are
long-term and they need that commitment
from right across government but we are
working at place to deliver them I have
been a long time person who believes
it's important to protect our natural
environment and to make sure that we
tackle things like climate change and
that's in a variety of ways I think they
all help in that regard you know having
that stability bringing peace and
prosperity the people and the planet
they go hand in hand and that's why
we'll continue to invest in programs
around the world thinking of climate and
Aid because we want to have stable
countries and food production
sustainable use of resources it all
comes together
right Victoria we're all waiting for
this deal that's meant to happen What by
Friday do we think that's going to
happen by Friday or will they have to
extend like we saw in Glasgow for cop
26.
well the official line is that we will
have um an overarching pack by the end
of the day on Friday I would be very
surprised if that happens and we're all
getting ready for some uh some late
nights and running well into Saturday at
least and one of the issues that it's
all really boiling down to and where
negotiations are becoming quite tense is
something that we've been hearing quite
a bit about it's this idea of
compensating vulnerable Nations for
climate impact things like the flooding
in Pakistan has really crystallized this
idea Pakistan has contributed very
little to climate change but clearly is
is Barry LeBron and party countries here
are really split on the issues got
vulnerable countries saying we need a
fund we need money to pay for this
problem that we didn't cause we don't
want to be borrowing even more to pay
for this and on the other side you've
got organizations I was speaking we've
got country sorry I was speaking with an
EU official earlier who said well
actually it's going to to take such a
long time to set up a fund what we need
instead is to just tweak existing levers
that we have tweak the way that IMF
works the World Bank look at debt relief
look at changing the way Insurance works
and and making that
um less less scared of risks so to speak
the fit and so and they say that that
would help these things get off the
ground much more quickly than waiting to
agree the fund the thing is that just
does not wash with the vulnerable
countries who just don't trust that the
money will materialize if we rely on
this sort of Patchwork of ideas that
many developed countries are pushing so
that is really the Hot Topic here okay
Victoria thank you so much um Victoria
is in Sean Shake of course let's go live
to that conference cop 27 in Egypt and
the president of Brazil there he is the
country which is home to that crucial
rainforest he's speaking now today he's
revealed that he wants to host a future
Summit in the Amazon
he's told delegates that Brazil is back
in the world his predecessor of course
Joe bolsonaro refused to host the annual
meeting in 2019 but president Da Silva
says he wants to host the cop 30 Summit
in the rainforest and this morning he
promised to radically change policies
with deforestation in the Amazon hitting
a 15-year High
Brazil can't remain isolated like it was
these last four years officials from
Brazil did a travel to any of the
countries and no other countries
traveled to Brazil
you all know that we're going to make a
big fight against the legal
deforestation
now the first Ministry of
say SNP politicians about how much
renewable energy is produced in Scotland
are wrong Nicholas sturgeon was speaking
as she unveiled one of the tallest anjal
wind turbines in Britain it's part of
the Wind Farm in South lanarkshire it's
now connected to the National Grid and
our Scotland correspondent Connor Gillis
asked the first Minister about
complaints from opposition parties about
figures given by the SNP about renewable
energy capacity
we know that the Scottish government has
repeatedly claimed that uh Scotland is
25 of Europe's offshore wind potential
that's incorrect that's misinformation
isn't it that's a dated figure which we
won't use anymore but you know it's I
think quite striking the extent to which
we have opposition politicians in
Scotland that are determined to talk
down a vast renewable energy potential
Scotland is a a global leader in wind
energy right now and the potential for
the future is fantastic and therefore we
should be celebrating that not having
arguments uh over whether or not
we want to talk it down in the way that
the opposition seem intended to do
well also in the news from around the
world today an environmental protester
who's gone on Hunger Strike has been
moved to hospital just stop oil says 34
year old Tes burns from Swansea started
their protest on Friday after being
arrested for trying to block the M25
Motorway the group say tez was moved
from prison after staff became concerned
about their health
and have a look at this one Iceland has
launched a new campaign to persuade
space tourists not to travel into orbit
the country's tourism board claims
visitors can experience what it's like
to walk on the surface of another planet
without generating a huge Cup in
footprint Iceland has apparently been
used as a filming location for Star Wars
and the Alien films and has served as a
training venue for NASA astronauts
preparing for their spacewalks do you
need the big suit though one wonders
before we go a reminder Tom Heap will be
presenting a special climate show this
weekend from charmel Sheikh focusing on
the end of cop27 and what if anything
gets achieved you can watch it on
Saturday and Sunday 7 30 in the evening
that's all for today just a reminder
full coverage of the Autumn statement
tomorrow means we'll be back on Friday
afternoon we'll see you then
[Music]